it's just after breakfast time they're
buying bread and preparing for the day
ahead welcome to haunt it's like this
every day the slippers don't stop nine
people have died on this street corner
this week not one had a gun she shouts
to me he's knocked our houses down we
have no electricity and no food yet you
foreigners are just doing nothing
nothing get us a no-fly zone the Arab
Spring has turned to winter but in Syria
people are still dying for wanting
freedom that is all there's a real sorry
over feeling about this he's not even
here in the background that's being
fairly continuous now for the last 15
minutes or so these streets should be
full of people cause they're not they're
hiding in alleyways trying to keep away
from it but every time somebody comes
out heavy tell me there's quite a little
while cuz shooting stars again
in an alleyway doctors in a field
hospital patch up the engine where Zoey
bonds where's are we born tell me where
do we build why they make that with us
tell me why he makes that with us the
snipers bullets care nothing about age
we can't even show the surgeons faces
they'll be shot for treating civilians
but nobody here is a soldier day after
day they're marrying the day 15 died in
a single attack in this suburb of homes
their defiance of the regime their
desire to bring about change in the face
of incredible repression is astounding
every funeral is a political statement
now every body laid to rest another
reason to fight they won't stop because
they're murdered by a regime that is
clinging on to power they're far from
winning but they don't seem to care
leaving to carry out this type of
funeral with a demonstration of
protester goes with it is extremely
dangerous as it direct opposition to the
government here and all these people are
in danger because they know that the
army is only a short distance away the
sun protection from the Free Syrian Army
but it's not very nice these people are
really angry and every determined to
show how they feel this fight for
democracy is nasty Assad uses militia to
attack crowds like this the shibir as
they're called don't care who dies
yessir Ozzy was gunned down he leaves a
wife and four children they have a photo
and memories of their father nothing
else he was just driving along a road it
started peacefully but it's changed now
a hundred yards from the Syrian
government troops the Free Syrian Army
protect babba armor they're a mix of
defected soldiers and volunteers
extremely well-organized but lacking in
real firepower Abby has very little
shabiha the militia don't care who they
kill all they wants to see his blood
their cousin they'll kill an old man
they'll kill a young child or get a
young lady and old lady they don't care
all they want to do is actually see
blood so we're here to protect our
people the Free Syrian Army basically
have a single job to try and protect the
ordinary people inside the many
districts of Homs that every night voice
their protest they run security checking
for shabbir infiltrators will cars in
and out to search
while we film their checkpoint a new
defector arrived it escaped from Daraa
far to the south was brought here by the
underground the whole length of the
country why have you defected this same
position shown then a shabu little high
little high I know bullseye realizes
he's killing his own people he's killing
innocent people he's killing people are
demonstrating without any weapons these
are the people he is joining in a side
street they risk everything to demand
change for 244 days straight they've
gathered to protest because it's a
capital offense just being here they're
in this street because the snipers can't
hit them if they could they would
they're just asking for a vote Bashar
al-assad is not a Moloch and not elected
is a dictator who took over from his
father with no mandate of any
description the army is keeping him in
power but these people won't change
how does the president respond with yet
another attack this is a warm day after
day after day it's like this in Homs it
never stops